foreign
what's up John Phoenix
hey how's it going John I'm good my
brother what's up
um so I
I just went through a really really uh
nasty divorce um I'm a Christian
Christian guy I'm 34 years old I had a
child with my
um ex-wife
um there's kind of a lot of trauma kind
of built in all of this so forgive me if
I get a little emotional but good man um
our child had had like uh had major
medical issues um when they were born
okay
um we were still married at the time we
got home and she
uh me and her long story short disagreed
about covid about you know I I was
trying to work and provide for my family
and I had them go in and meet my client
and
um she took uh took our child that day
and separated left
um we we had had problems you know in
the rest of the year too but sorry I'm
kind of running around but it's all
right man it's a full back story
um so my question is I divorce is
finalized I have 50 50 and I am owing
her still child support and I am having
a really hard time
um just
not just dealing with everything it's
just like financially it's also kind of
a burden and I'm I'm just struggling
I've been you know I'm trying to find
like a Biblical approach or a way to
look at it where
um it doesn't cause any more you know
anger hurt and resentment you know
toward her but I'm just I'm really
frustrated that
um like I did not file you know she left
she filed and I feel like no I'm getting
punished forever with this and I just
don't know
I don't know if I'll be able to say but
for a house I don't know if I'll ever be
able to
have like a great you know life still
while having a be a single dad pay for
all the EXP like I still have to pay for
child care on my side and I'm just she
has a bunch of family here and I'm you
know paying and she could work but she's
not and
I just don't know what to do
I can hear it on you man and I
I am heartbroken that your marriage
didn't make it
um I would be willing to bet there was
challenges that covet was not the first
thing that happened
um 100 there was probably some really
heaviness in the water that made the
coven became the lightning rod or became
the focal point and it's not uncommon
unfortunately that kids with special
needs the kids with exceptional medical
issues
um split husbands and wives up because
the grieving process is so unique to
individuals and someone's like why can't
believe you're not concerned about this
or I can't believe you you're just gonna
go watch a movie when our kid is right
and then the other one is like you
expect me to shut down my light right
and people just go to war
um and it really again it's kind of like
money
um the the kid who's struggling is
really the symptom not the issue right
the issue is below that but here you are
you found yourself there
um I think
um I made I may get my dates off I think
75 76 77 something like that was when
um the whole like child support came in
to be right and it was the idea of it
was trying to keep the nuclear for Kelly
will you check on that like the origin
of Child Support
um but the idea was
still then in the 70s there was a
nuclear family generally speaking mom
stayed home
um Dad work and it was a way to keep the
family looking like it originally did
1950 okay okay
um so I was off 25 years
so that's about right on the show uh
1950. the idea was we're going to keep
the nuclear family looking as close as
possible so mom is still going to stay
home with the kids that check is still
going to show up here and dad is was
usually the one that chose to leave okay
so there's it's it still has some
Shadows to that
um here's the hard reality
I'm gonna say y'all and I know that your
response is going to be that's not true
I didn't file okay but I'm gonna say
y'all on purpose and feel free to push
back when I get done saying what I'm
gonna say okay
okay you all entered into a marriage
and you entered into a legal marriage
and y'all for whatever reason made
decisions
whether on the front end in the middle
on the back end or finally with your
with your ex-wife filing
you all made choices to not handle the
disagreements or handle the relational
matters yourself
and because you entered into a legal
Arrangement the dissolution of that
legal Arrangement put the here's what's
going to happen in the hands of a
government official in the hands of a
judge
and the judge made their choice
and what I would tell you is any
anger rage frustration any of the I'm
gonna
that's a choice you are making to be
miserable in the present
any time you spent thinking well she
could be working and she should have
been
that's a choice to be miserable in the
present
and it's something you gotta grieve it's
okay to be frustrated about it it's okay
to be angry about it
all the all your feelings everything's
okay
the reality is the judge spoke
the judge made a declaration a divorce
decree was signed and regardless of what
you think should have happened or I
think it is it's just an is you can go
hire a lawyer and somebody to tell you
that I'll go fight this for you and you
can spend ten thousand or twenty
thousand bucks trying to get another
200 reduced from your total bill every
month you can do that
here's where I would focus my energy in
your situation
I would focus my energy on making sure
that me because you're gonna have a
relationship with this woman for the
rest of your life
forever when your kids get married she's
gonna be there when your kids are in the
hospital she's gonna be you're gonna
have a relationship with her forever
the sooner you can make peace with not
her we're not gonna be best friends
We're Not Gonna Be lovers again but
we're going to be adults in a
relationship for the rest of our lives
we gotta act like adults that means I'm
gonna have to put my anger and rage down
because it's what's best for these kids
and the sooner she can do that too y'all
can begin to co-parent these kids in a
way that is going to keep it's going to
minimize the divorce trauma it's going
to minimize The Angst and frustration
and yelling they've absorbed for the
last one two three however many years
and so honestly man I think your energy
is best spent
looking forward if I've got to get
another job I got another job if I have
to get a supplemental job for a season I
got to get a supplemental job first
start being about Solutions and not
sitting in this
so I just threw a lot at you and this is
just me talking to my buddy over a drink
you know at a local joint like tell me
what you think what you're feeling when
I say that stuff
no I I I kind of I'm agreeing and
there's some things I'm also not like on
the same so
she has a great career too so I'm not
not trying to like circumvent that I'm
trying to part part of this
there's a lot of backstory too on this
there were um false allegations made
um against me that I had to uh basically
you know go in with my attorney and
thankfully there were a bunch of cameras
everything I was innocent but I was
you know basically blamed falsely and
when I went in there and
proved that
um the judge made it to me where me and
her can never communicate again except
by email okay
um they were that bad so her her family
um her sister testified like you know in
court we proved it wrong her sister went
to jail for a while okay there so for
perjury heavy
yes
really sorry for lying I'm I'm sorry
maybe not perjury lying under lying
under oath yes
what do they accuse you of
um they said that I went over there and
I was just I was trying to see my son
and they were not letting um I was
seeing him and she started uh basically
yelling at me asking me to leave and I
tried to leave with my son there was
um unfortunately some physical stuff
that happened between her father and I
and they called the police and the
police came over
um out after the fact and there there
was a camera right across the street
that captured everything outside with me
trying to leave with my son and the
whole conflict and everything and
um her sister and her made all these
other claims that were not even remotely
true and so
um but I was
you you thought you thought you heard
your father-in-law
yeah how was that yeah
um not good but it was uh I'm glad I got
can I just say I hope it's okay to say
this you say whatever you wanted I got a
couple good looks then because I got you
know who's bigger than I was but I got a
couple good ones so it was okay it's
just awful hey but you know I was
thinking I
yeah I I I just it was um I shouldn't
laugh about it but it was no I'm trying
to break the attention here I can hear
it on you man so
um yeah I know there's millions of guys
who are like I bet I could take that old
man and then that old man's like I've
got Dad's drink I I might not be able to
wipe properly for the next six months
but I will win this fight right now
right so anyway you did it you actually
fought your father-in-law so there you
go man there you go I got it I got a
couple good licks in and but they yeah
so then they wouldn't let me they made
you know there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that happened okay so so let's you
know what you're telling me is perfect
because here here's the deal
there's such an emotional charge here
there's literally physical altercations
that happen there was lying there's
somebody in jail now there was all kinds
of allegations that were just completely
bogus nonsense
and yet here we are
here we are
and you're looking at this decree
she might be an attorney that makes five
hundred thousand dollars a year
your ex-wife and you might be a plumber
and you make 52.
none of that matters man
the paper says you got to help out with
child support I'm just going to help out
with child support man
what I would much rather have is a
20-year record
for my son when my son turns 30
and I'm just assuming your kids I don't
know how old your kid is but
um I want my kid when they turn 25
to have a record of dad never missed
because the truth will come out by the
way and if your ex-wife is someone who
lies someone who weaponizes her child
someone who demonizes
it will it will it will resurface and
what you're doing now relational is
you're playing a 15 or 20 or 30 year
game with your with your son
okay
the truth will will be known and there
will be a 20-year or an 18-year however
long I guess it's going to be an eight
year
um but it will be an eight-year
um record dead never missed a payment
this wasn't about supporting mom this
wasn't about trying to prop her this is
about taking care of my baby
I always showed up I always showed up
and that's what we're playing a
forward-looking game NADA can you
believe this all happened again because
if you go back to court it's not about
your kid it's about you think you got
beat in court and you don't think you
should have lost
yeah I'm sorry just to I'll say this
really quick I don't feel that way I
feel like just
I got 50 50. I am so grateful John for
that I know there's a lot of good Dads
that got you know traditionally in the
past right had did not get that and
they're with these other these these
allegations and stuff that were I mean I
thought I was never going to see him
again you know sorry for a little
emotional I mean I thought I was done
and thankfully you know God there were
things set in place so I can see him and
be in his life and I you know I'm not
quitting on him I love him and oh I know
you're not I know you're not struggling
because you know it's just it like I'm
just looking at I'm like well we got 50
50. why am I she has a a great career
why am I giving her anything like why
can we not just split this for him down
the middle amicably and I just don't
understand why I'm getting the
and what I would say is I totally get
the struggle and mathematically that
struggle makes sense philosophically
that struggle makes sense
but when y'all two chose
her maybe more than you okay maybe way
more than you but when you all chose to
not be able to reconcile your challenges
together
you you offloaded that responsibility to
a third party and that third party made
their choice
and so we're sitting in the middle of
that choice
we were sitting in the middle of that
decision
and if she goes back to work
then you might have a court case
if she's staying at home because of the
trauma of her husband ex-husband was so
dude I'm gonna write my check I'm going
to love the snot out of that kid and
then I'm gonna go make my career the
best it can be I'm gonna engage in
relationships that are good for me that
are healthy for me and I'm going forward
man
I'm going forward
okay any choice to hang around with that
past is a choice to be weighed down
and it's gonna feel like lightning bolts
the rage
you're gonna have something cool come up
and you're gonna have just written how
how much is the check
um it is about 400 a month okay
um it's not it's so I'll just say this
word it's not even so much the
I make a pretty good living and so but
she does as well and I'm just frustrated
because I feel like
not to keep going back but I'm like it
should be 50 50. I don't feel like yep
you know and you're gonna look listen
you're gonna get stuck on the loop
you're gonna get stuck on the loop on
the loop on the loop on the loop on the
loop
it should be and it's not
kids should not get cancer and they do
my buddies shouldn't have gotten a car
wreck and died
he did
and he did
there's so much of our lives that
shouldn't that is
you
um had somebody try to destroy your life
and take your son away from you
and it didn't happen
and but you do have to pay 400 bucks a
month
probably shouldn't have to but it is it
is
and so cool I'm gonna write that four
dollar check and I refuse I refuse
to give her another
room in my head rent free
to to take joy from my life
I refuse I'm not going to give her that
here's your 400.
love my son the best you can I'm I'm on
I'm on to the next with my day
and the loop will start the lightning
bolts will pop in your head when you're
writing that check you'll be so mad or
when that check gets just taken out of
your account you'll get angry and that's
when you have a choice to make am I
going to meditate on this that's 50
freaking 50 and they shouldn't or am I
going to Exhale through and go I'm so
grateful that I don't have to worry at
all that my son's got the financial
resources he needs
now I'm going now I'm going to the gym
now I'm calling my buddy now I'm going
to fill in the blank whatever else comes
next
you see what I'm saying this is a total
reorientation of your life
yeah yeah okay every time one of those
things pop in your head I keep a journal
I write it down I like look it's right
here dude I put like cool tough stickers
on it and stuff so I look all hard
um but it's really just like a diary
it's and it's I got it
write them down we were frustrated when
you're upset
and to be as adult as an adult as an
adult as you can be on the other side of
it and be about what can I can control
here I can't control the 400 bucks cool
I'm gonna write my four dollar check I'm
gonna move on
and then I'm gonna be about you can't
save up for a house
you can
you can work really hard for the next 18
months on a promotion you can work
really hard to get some new skills you
can work really hard on moving to
another career another job you can do
those things you'll get a house
you absolutely get a house it's gonna be
awesome
you're gonna pay for half of it in cash
right you're gonna you're gonna be able
to work that stuff out right now you're
still in the Aftershock of
the breakup of your marriage you never
saw yourself as a single dad you never
saw yourself as a d as someone who gets
gets divorced you never saw yourself as
someone who failed you never saw you so
you gotta have to reconcile with this
whole new you
and you can
and you will because you're a person of
character
live moving forward
unchain yourself from the past my
brother